welcome back everyone it's round two
recap
from the national open tournament in
vegas
if you missed the first recap it's on my
youtube channel
you can check it out it's this video
right here um and before we get into
the game itself i do want to share
a photo from before the game
i was on board 2 playing one of the top
seeds
grand master benjamin gledora a very
strong player from hungary
i believe he's top 150 in the world
yeah you can see the fide ratings here
so feeder rating of 2633
um i first heard of his name
several years ago when he beat anand it
was like some amazing
upset from some tournament and then i
actually got to train with him
in st louis let me see if i have some
more photos
yeah so i trained with him in st louis
at
uh webster university he's now actually
a student there
but even before he was a student he came
to visit and train with our team
and i played some training games with
him so he's
uh he's definitely a very strong player
um
and i knew i had my work cut out for me
so i didn't have much time to prepare
this was a morning round
or no it was afternoon round round
started at noon
but i woke up like sometime in the
morning and
the pairings didn't go up until maybe
like an hour or two before
so there wasn't much time to do like
extensive opening preparation
but before the game i decided i would
play the london it's a safe choice
i knew that my preparation is solid
enough to hopefully not get a losing
position
too quickly now
unfortunately he was very well prepared
and he blitzed out
basically his first 10 moves not too
much
thought and he played a very respectable
line
that i i did not look at look at this
line specifically beforehand
um so i'll go ahead and show uh what he
did is
went for an early c5 now most of the
time
black will have like committed to knight
f6
but he played a move order which avoids
a lot of the main lines and he actually
delayed knight f6 for so long that later
he managed to develop the knight
to e7 and c5
very respectable pressuring the pawn
right away
enables queen b6 in some cases i play e3
knight c6 knight f3 and then he goes for
bishop g4
and even though i'm like a very regular
london player i play a ton online
this is a position i don't encounter too
often
just because a knight is usually here by
now
now i still had some idea what to do and
the next move i play is uh it's actually
kind of tricky
it's it's one of the main developing
moves is knight b
d2 and after i play this move i
screamed out oh no my pawn
because it looks like black can actually
take a pawn on d4
like takes takes and then
the knights pinned um i didn't actually
scream out but i was imagining like what
would
what would the room be like if i just
shouted oh no my pawn
this is a trap if black takes a pawn
then i can actually take back
say oh no my queen link below for merch
and if i lose the queen bishop e5 queen
d7
takes takes take with a rook and lights
up a piece
um and this is actually a reverse
version of the elephant trap
which can happen in a queen's gambit
where black is trapping white
i'll link below i've had some youtube
video recently where i show the elephant
trap
if people are curious but basically this
pawn it's defended by tactics
and my opponent was good enough not to
fall for such a simple trap
so he plays e6 i play c3
and now he was very particular with the
move order and
he played a move that i was hoping i
wouldn't see
but was to be expected as pawn takes
pawn
um now i'll explain the move i was
hoping he would play as knight f6
which on the surface looks like very
very stable for black
just very harmonious piece development
leaving the tension between the pawns
and we got to this position i would have
been very happy to play this line queen
a4
which sets up a really cool trap if
black plays
one of the most natural moves it's the
second most played move on leachat's
bishop d6
white has an instantly winning move like
after white's next move it just wins
material
on the spot that move being bishop a6
and this is a this is a london trap that
i think
most grand masters would not fall for in
like a slow classical game
but i still had like some ounce of hope
now i want to i don't want to get into
the nitty-gritty of the lines which can
emerge from here
um but if you do want further analysis
from this position
i had a pretty extensive lesson a few
months ago with andrea botez where we
uh we dug into these lines and i show
exactly why that uh
the engine gives plus three for white in
this position
so what happened the game is after pawn
jake's pawn pawn digs pawn
bishop d6 i'm not really in time to
cause much
disturbance or tactics on the queen side
and the game actually turns into a more
kind of positional battle
i draw back very typical in london where
you
leave the bishop here so i'm always
happy if black wants to
exchange on g3 and have me open the h
file
um so 97 was played
which i think it's probably more useful
than knight f6
just because black stays more flexible
uh keeps option open and playing f6 e5
also has possibilities of knight five
so already at this point i feel like
black
kind of got what he wanted in the
opening the position is relatively equal
but that's a thing like sometimes when
you play the london if black knows what
they're doing they can equalize but it's
still a fight
and the game is not at all determined in
the opening it's determined later on
in the middle game and end game as we'll
see in this game
so uh i play bishop e2 castle
and i go for the early knight h4
and this move probably takes some
explaining like why do i put my knight
on the edge
it was mainly to trade off the light
squared bishops
um and then just make the position a bit
more easier for me to play
this is also a prophylactic move because
there's cases where
if i castle then black can get in knight
f5 and then i have to
either concede the bishop pair or spend
more time moving my bishop again
and then black can activate further so
we trade on e2 takes and now
i'm hiding the notation because black's
next move i think is very very
instructive
and it's a move that i actually wasn't
expecting during the game
um which i want to pose pose this
as kind of a positional exercise for
viewers
because we're reaching a point where the
game is transitioning from the opening
into the middle game and it's a question
of what black wants to do in the
position
so feel free to pause the video and
try and figure out like how you continue
play
from this position as black
and before i say what my opponent played
i'll say what i was expecting
i was expecting black to go for a6
and then carry through with b5 and
um i should note that this structure
that we have
where i'm missing an e-pawn black is
missing a c-pawn
it's called the carlsbad structure this
can come from a variety of different
openings
and usually in this sort of pawn
structure
one of the main plans is to minority
attack
um and by minority attack i mean
black has a two on three minority
so it's very typical to use upon
minority in this case
these two pawns to lunge forward ideally
play
b4 and then create some weakness
in my structure and i was kind of
beginning to think like as
as my opponent was taking time in this
position i was thinking okay if a6 i can
slow him down with
a4 and it's going to take some time
before black can
expand however
my opponent just played b5 immediately
and
once he played this i realized oh no
this minority attack is happening like
really really quickly
and this move was kind of a blind spot
for me because
i just assumed without thinking too much
further that i could take the pawn
of course when he played it i realized i
can't really get away with taking the
pawn without allowing this
and this would be a good trade for black
i'll move like let's say queen a4
rook takes b2 um i'd be left with a more
glaring weakness on c3 the rook would
activate
during the game i was trying to make
lines like knight b3 work to trap the
rook
but it's it's not too realistic though
the rook
will usually have a square um if i do
end up attacking it
i was dreaming of like castling to trap
the rook but
the lines just don't work out and engine
will
will say blacks already significantly
better here
so during the game
i wasn't entirely sure
how to just meet the threat of
of b4 no it's not a tactical threat but
it is a positional threat
of weakening my structure so i decided
to throw an a3
black goes ahead plays b5 again leaving
the pawn hanging but
um pawn is not truly hanging because
black has rook b8s
and then i decide to castle um the plan
i went for in this game
was to allow the minority attack because
it's hard to stop and i went for the
trade
takes on b4 now it's important for black
hair not to take back right away
the queen would be overworked here i
would take and then with material
so first black takes on g3
takes and then takes and
got to this position and went for the
the simple plan
of bringing my knight to c5
so even though i very likely will wind
up with a backwards pawn
and an arguably just worse pawn
structure and the venti
takes takes i have two
uh two pawn islands double pawns aren't
so weak but the backwards pawn on a half
open file
is not the most pleasant situation but i
did figure that
i could get a nice outpost for my knight
and not only is this an outpost but it
it would block the c file so black would
have a harder time actually
um getting to attack the pawn now
in the game we got to this position and
black
played queen v6 which i think is very
reasonable
leaving the tension between the pawns
and
now the threat of course is to take and
attack the knight
so i go in knight c5 threatening the
the fork rook a7
and i bring my knight back my knight no
longer really had a purpose here
um and there's definitely better squares
my
kingside knight can can go to as we'll
see
rogate i trade queen takes
and in this position i realized that
most of black's pieces are just
really out of play um especially far
away from the king side
so this is an opportunity where
i can i can try and stir up some
initiative
on the king's side and that definitely
explains my next move
knight g5 and this is a move like i feel
like a lot of players might play without
seeing a clear purpose but of course i
have a very direct threat of queen h5
um maybe some reminiscent position to
stafford gambit
attacking these two very delicate pawns
so black is immediately on the defensive
here
and not only am i threatening queen h5
but i'm keeping
possibilities of stacking on e6 which
could happen in some situations for
example
not sure if this line would work but
knight g6 or there's some possibility of
taking
where it takes takes and i hit the king
at night
and i'm realizing if rookie here pinning
i have this move
so black has to be really careful here
and he was careful in the game he played
very kind of ugly passive looking move
knight t8 but it does its job
kind of defending the two two of the
focal points
i i wanted to target and i was not
expecting this move
uh this move was not on my radar but i
was happy to see it
given the knight is now just purely
defensive
and during the game i of course
considered queen h5
and assumed h6 would lead to just a
a reasonably solid position for black
like i don't really
make much progress so i went the other
direction and i play queen b5
which is actually a nice move because
i'm threatening the pawn
but i'm also threatening maiden one
which
is kind of surprising that this is a
mate threat but then like cuts off the
back rank
and it forces black to do some more
awkward things
um opponent played knight e
to c6 now i should note knight
dc6 is also possible but that would give
me the option of repeating
i'm not sure if i would go for
repetition but
i think as a higher rate player by
by a few hundred rating points my
opponent of course wanted to
keep winning chances alive and knight
dc6
uh even though it leaves this knight
like very stuck on d8
it does kind of cover this and also
it makes it so i don't really want to
take with a pawn
black can't take right away because
there's mates but my pawns would be weak
there's rook b8 and black can win back
the pawn
so in this position i went for queen d3
so i figured my queen did its job it
made the knight move to where the other
knight wants to go
so black has what we call superfluous
knights
and i keep my initiative by threatening
h7
opponent plays g6 and here i play
g4 which i thought is a it's a typical
move in the structure
not only to fantasize about situations
where i can later
maneuver the knight around play g5 and
maybe get a knight to f6 someday
with a nice outpost but more
uh what's the word more quickly attack
with queen h3
and just go after the one of the clear
targets in the position
unfortunately it turned out g4 was
not quick enough because black strikes
with queen e7
and my knights attacked i don't have
time for queen h3
so i play queen e3 and my plan here is
now
to move the knight back and potentially
invade the dark squares
so black plays knight a5 hitting
nothing physical but hitting squares so
there is
some idea of knight c4
however and this is this is probably one
of the most key
moments like if you analyze with engine
so i should address this
this move turned out to be
a i think it was either an accuracy or a
mistake
um and we can see by the engine
evaluation
software says this is equal after knight
a5
it gave me the option of taking which i
only briefly considered during the game
i didn't really want to make my pawn
structure
so ugly like this but this was an
opportunity for me one of the biggest
opportunities in the game
to get the advantage because i keep
initiative
on the knights and if knight c4
we just follow the engine line there's a
nice move queen f4
keeping pressure very active queen also
preventing rook b8s
and black spends the time to recapture
the pawn
i can play rook b1 and white's actually
in full control here
where now i have a past b-pawn supported
by the rook my knight is happy my other
knight's happy
box pieces are kind of sad and defensive
so
looking back on this i kind of wish i i
spent more
more time considering pawn takes pawn
but i did have different ideas in mind
move i played was knight f3 uh going
through with my plan of
trying to get in queen h6 and like comes
back and target h7
this did allow knight c4 and after queen
h6
black takes takes and plays f6
so very nice move actually not only
preventing knight g5 but also
just covering h7 maybe some idea of
queen g7
also more likely knight f7 hitting my
queen the move i played here i was happy
about
but it turned out to still be
complicated i played g5 now of course
for those that watch my twitch stream
and for the subscribers of my twitch
stream you should know
i have the the g5 emote
which maybe i can show it's one of my
favorite moves in chess
because uh usually whenever you play it
you're either like attacking with a
white or you're being crazy with black
you can subscribe on twitch if you want
access to this emote
but when i played in the game it was
for purely positional reasons
i wanted to access e5 square i also
wanted to induce black to play f5
was that f5 played right away it was
which leaves a very ugly
backwards pawn on e6 where i thought
going forward from here i can go put a
rook on the e file
and black's going to be purely defensive
and i'm controlling
e5 enough times unfortunately there were
some moves i overlooked coming up very
soon
after rook e1 black
first okay maneuvers and knights some
idea of
knight e4 so i played 95 i'm still happy
and now knight app seven this is a very
precise move
i should note if this knight goes to f7
which looks more natural
there is some possibility of knight
takes g6 i actually didn't analyze this
afterwards
but this apparently is playable
so other knight coming to f7
makes it so knight takes g6 is less
powerful because after takes takes takes
king f8
uh this pawn
[Music]
this pawn could be taken but it's
defended actually i don't know what's
going on
queen takes c5 oh queen takes e5
because my queen's also hanging
stockfish knows best
anyway okay knights uh knight six f7 was
played i should say
and uh the game continues so i
uh i trade first on f7
takes takes and then i move all the way
back
to h2 and i
still was happy with the position um
even though g5 looks like it's falling
e6 is still weak and i was expecting
this online
like takes and then um i can't take here
immediately but there's some queen f4
move
and i thought everything was fine i
missed
black's next move and after black's next
move i thought i was in trouble
opponent plays e5 which for some reason
i just completely overlooked
um thinking that this was only an option
the e5 was a really
nice also timely move even though i have
one
two three attackers there's only two
defenders
my pawn is tied down to defending my
knights
and i can't take with rook because my
takes so
i was feeling the pressure here and at
this
point just because i overlooked e5 i
thought i was worse
in reality i was completely fine i
actually found like the next
few best options
um i play queen g3
defending the pawn improving the queen
e4 is played
and then rook to b1
and this turned out to be the last plan
uh just going
for counter play and basically
abandoning the
the g pawn there is another plan
i was considering during the game i was
happy i didn't go for it
um but it looked kind of cool was knight
d3
intending to maybe play knight e5 or
knight f4
this move would fail miserably
and i think this is another good kind of
tactical moment for viewers
if you want to pause the video and find
the absolutely winning move for black
feel free to do so i'll admit i didn't
see
black's best move from this position in
the game but we didn't go into this line
so it didn't affect things but the move
back in play
is pawn takes knight oh no black's queen
and then d2 and there is no
good way to stop the pawn from promoting
uh if queen f3 there's rook check
black will promote and b up a knight
and there's not enough counter play for
white
so it was a funny line um
but i didn't go into it i play rook b1
losing a pawn but getting a check
and after trade trade
i should mention the time control we
were playing kind of a
long slightly unusual time control
where on mu 40
we get an extra half hour each
but leading up to move 40 i had
i think less than five minutes like we
were both running
relatively low on time and
my next few moves i i had to play
quickly um
so queen d8 was played play queen b7
and now queen d6 so it's a question
really if i can stir up enough
counter play with my knight and queen
for being down a pawn
i played queen c8 here
king 2 g7 i think the next move
is my 39th move so i was under pressure
time-wise i had to play quickly i played
knight
e6 in hindsight
actually 96 engine still says is best
um but in hindsight i probably the very
least i should have considered queen e6
which was not even a candidate move but
it's a nice idea
to go for a queen trade and if takes
takes
king f6 i can win the d-pawn either with
this
or this where i prevent king e6 and
i'll win the d-pawn and then this would
likely just be a
a pretty routine draw but i play 96
king f6 i move to c7
i thought i was being sneaky because i'm
threatening the fork the king can't
return to g7
there's also possibilities where i just
go and attack the pawn
and the queen is only defender so
i was feeling relatively good here
but as we'll see my opponent came up
with some really really nice ideas
i actually managed to win the game like
pretty quickly
like this is move 40. i was
dead lost like the game just ended on mu
49. so black won this position in nine
more moves
which looking back it's kind of hard to
predict how
my position can go south really quickly
but uh we will see so
he starts with king g5 now in this
position
i played 96 my first intention
was to play queen b7 thinking oh i'm
winning a pawn
unfortunately there's 98
and i don't have any time to take the
pawn if i take with queen i lose my
knight
and if i take with knight i lose my
queen
so then i was kind of sad and that's why
i played 96 thinking okay i'll keep
trying to harass the king
and my opponent pretty quickly played
king g4
so walking up further and it's a really
unusual situation where the king is
delved into my territory but the pawns
shelter the king
from a different side than usual
it's like it's like holding an umbrella
but
you're sheltering your feet because the
water is coming
from the reverse dirt like the ground is
raining i don't know
analogies are hard sometimes so anyway i
was slightly flustered
but the game keeps going and i play c4
and i'll say that c4 was my
intention i think i was more expecting
king h6
but the reason why i play c4 was to
try and resolve the
the backwards pawn on c3
and i will say this this is my worst
move of the game
like c4 was was really really bad
blunder
but it's not so obvious why it's so bad
so i played c4 thinking okay i'm either
gonna get in c5
and get a defended passer or we'll trade
i take with queen keep my knight
defended and then i have a pass deepon
and then there's room to try and target
black's king
i was dreaming of situations where
black will just get mated with the king
here like
king h4 only legal move check here and
then
mate of course none of that happened
and my opponent played the next move
relatively quickly which
kind of bedazzled me because the next
move i i just
disregarded pretty quickly when i played
c4
next move being queen b4 and i
disregarded this because
i have queen c7 here
so like during the game in this position
i was calculating okay
c4 i saw queen b4 as an option
i assumed okay queen c7 just refutes
everything it hits the knights
it threatens many nasty checks
actually just force mate threat against
the king um
and i assumed okay queen b4 is not
possible
my mistake was i didn't look far enough
i only looked what two moves ahead like
one and then two um i
should have looked at least like five or
six moves ahead
and this is like the key separating
factor
between my level and his level at least
in this moment
is looking far enough and uncovering
kind of a hidden resource in uh
in the variation um
is after queen b4 okay i play queen c7 i
don't have
too many other options as queenie one's
a threat
it turns out that black is completely
winning here
and after queenie one only legal move
king h2 queen takes f2
[Music]
and all of a sudden black is just
preventing the two checks i wanted to do
black is also sacrificing at night which
i did end up taking
um at this moment i realized oh i'm in
trouble
but there's not much i can do like
otherwise so i took the knight
and after check
king g1 e3
it's such a weird position i was
actually really impressed like during
the game my opponent was playing
relatively quickly
like found queen b4 pretty quickly
and probably just like saw the the
possibility of this line
and the problem for white here
even though i have a queen and knight
the black king is on g4
i have no effective way of
attacking the king and black just wants
to make a new queen
so i took a lot of time here like
searching for any
possible resource probably took like 10
or 15 minutes because i don't want to
resign if there's some like brilliant
comeback but uh
it turns out the position is just
defenseless for white
and the the king is actually a useful
attacking piece
and the pawns keep it safe in the game i
played queen c7
um hoping for some miracle queen f4
but then after queen f2 so now the queen
again defends these squares
i play king h2 e2
i have no checks and black is ready to
make a queen
i tried one more move takes h7
hoping and praying blackwood queen and
then i can
beautiful mate like this but then queen
g3 and that's just made in two
i actually resigned here i guess i could
have played this and given my opponent
the chance to under promote
to rook with mates but um
but it was actually a really nice finish
from black and
going from a position which stockfish
says
is actually very close to equal here he
found
the one the one way to like create
winning chances and
it put me in a a tough situation
um looking back on this i guess
stockfish does want me to play this
allow this and
just put the queen here um
but there's there's still kind of a
nagging edge for that given that
there's an extra pawn the pawn majority
can be scary in some situations and
the game just continues so
anyway it was a cool game i i wasn't too
upset after losing this game
given that my opponent just found a
really really nice idea
and the tactical line really wasn't so
obvious
the the thing i i should really improve
on next time
is heightening my awareness for danger
levels
now i've i reviewed this game on on live
stream
i think the evening uh it was played and
i mentioned to my uh
my chat that during some of my games in
vegas
i had the the danger levels wrap
from gotham chess stuck in my mind
but i really should have had actual
danger levels
of being aware when my king is a
potential target
and if i just looked a few moves further
maybe i would have
come up with a better move apparently
queen e8
is the best try here and then would
still take a lot of work for black to
convert this position
so anyway i think that turned out to be
a
long recording wow yeah that's uh it's
gonna be over a half hour video but i
hope people enjoyed that
let me know if you made it to the end
and uh if you have any questions feel
free to leave a comment
i'll leave a link to this leachat study
where i do all the analysis so if you
want to analyze on your own
or with the engine and opening book you
can do so
and stay tuned for another recap also
stay tuned for more live streams
if you follow me on twitch i'll be
streaming on the coming days
and you can get notified when i go live